hey guys this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so i've been working as
a professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and right now i'm doing youtube videos
because guys i want to pass the
knowledge i want to explain to you
how pro traders are working how i work
what is working for me what tools i use
what is efficient
and i know that you can find a lot of
different stuff on the internet some is
good some is bad
so i'm here actually to show you what is
actually working
and how to use it precisely so if you
want to know about
all this stuff you are in the right
place so today i want to make an update
on socket mobile
let's get into it
[Music]
so i did a video on socket mobile last
week
so the stock just went uh higher you
know by
insane levels we're talking about three
five thousand
percent you know so it's a very small
cap okay so the question is
where are the support levels i don't
like to buy things where they are
already flying guys all right i like to
buy them while they're correcting
of course i'm going to miss some trades
but you know the ones i'm going to have
are going to be less risky so here if
you want to buy it when it's flying a
very nice level is actually
nine quite easy guys it's just the
recent lows that we had since uh the
crazy gap up and breakout of all-time
highs
so this level actually all time size
all-time highs are higher but whatever
so nine is a very less nice level to buy
so you can buy at nine and stop lost
titan i don't know eight something like
this
and try to capture some strong move up
if it breaks
uh the nine level then the next level is
five guys
five is a very nice target why five
because here is the most recent high
all right i don't have uh recent lows
because we have not traded here there
was no consideration
so the only data i have is this and if
we break five then the next one is gonna
be three
so you know the stuff can go lower so
careful and for now
nine is a strong support below nine guys
you need to reconsider your analysis
let's quickly check uh what is the short
interest on the stuff
i think it's too small to get shorted
you know so
first market cap you see 60 million guys
amc is 102 billion all right so this is
a penny penny penny stock
so i don't know show the interest yeah
they don't
care they don't care you know of course
they don't care because when the market
cap is 60 million the maximum money you
can make by shorting in the 60 million
so it's not interesting for hedge funds
so this is a very very small market cap
institutional
ownership i'm pretty sure okay they're
buying it but the data is not updated
you know they bought one million dollar
it's mean nothing
so guys this is too small to have real
information so once again i go market
beat
market watch the date is updated every
two weeks we cannot say anything
more about the stuff so support that
nine and then we'll see what happens
all right guys that's it for me i hope
you enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to show i see you guys